Donald Trump gibt sich zu Spekulationen über eine Präsidentschaftskandidatur
von Oprah Winfrey gelassen.
Er könne sie besiegen, sagte der US-Präsident am Dienstag vor Journalisten.
"Oprah wäre ein großer Spaß.
Ich kenne sie sehr gut.
Ich mag sie", sagte Trump.
Er glaube aber nicht, dass sie kandidiere.
Auch eine Vertraute der US-Fernsehmoderatorin erklärte, Winfrey sei zwar von der Idee
einer Kandidatur "fasziniert", erwäge den Schritt derzeit aber nicht.
Die 63-Jährige wurde im Internet als potenzielle Gegenkandidatin zu Trump gehandelt,
nachdem sie bei der Golden-Globe-Verleihung für Frauen- und Bürgerrechte geworben hatte.
Die nächste US-Präsidentenwahl steht 2020 an.